réponse tient cinq ananas la réponse et
5 ananas alors oui avec ma femme de
belles salades avec ont fait une belle
salade on nous rassure on peut poser la
question si on n'est pas sûr on peut
poser bien sûr ananas à à un ananas
frais qu'elle a la taille de fabien
lecoeuvre
qu'est-ce qui a été utilisé dans une
campagne de pub aux antilles pour la
d'inattention sont la double filiation
sociale très bonne résilience d'amina
oui amina comme vous êtes dans le public
cathy venez vous votre point à valérie
benaïm merci merci à mina donc c'est
valérie c'est vous un sujet très très
très très heureuse il faut pas lire il
brave au chili en martinique moyens
parce qu'en martinique c'est bon je
prend alors une affiche de
sensibilisation à la distanciation
sociales mises en ligne par la
préfecture de martinique vendredi à
chaud pts et vos internautes regarder
cette affiche jugée acide et d'ananas
ont été pris comme unité de mesure on
vous a tout résumé regarder ça / amy
alors que toutes les régions tentent de
rester ou de passer en zone verte chacun
y va de son affiche et de ses messages
de prévention pour tenter d'endiguer
l'épidémie
sauf que voilà certains messages ont
parfois été mal interprétés c'est par
exemple le cas en martinique où la
préfecture a décidé de personnaliser le
message de prévention liée à la
distanciation social en illustrant le
mètre de distance par un visuel de 5
ananas sur internet très vite certains
internautes y ont vu un dérapage raciste
c'est plus facile à mesurer en ananas
banane pour les indigènes pour les
habitants même chose du côté de jean luc
mélenchon la macro ni ses sets sont
aussi en australie ce sont des
kangourous qui ont été utilisées pour
illustrer la distanciation social quant
à la polynésie française ce sont des
noix de coco
alors est ce que ça vous choque dit la
vérité ou pas du tout alors ya jean luc
mélenchon qui est allé voilà qui est à
quai à quai par un bon prix vous est ce
que est ce que ça vous choque
moi ce qui me choque c'est les personnes
qui trouvent ça raciste c'est à dire
qu'une personne qui trouve ce truc lara
cccl même quelqu'un de raciste parce que
oui pour l assaut disponibles sont
celles ci vous voyez qu'il ya des koala
en australie banc mais des koalas s'il
ya des cookies mon enfance mais des
coquelicots si la fin je sais pas je
paraît qu'en tunisie moi je séchais
women et les babouches bah voilà séparé
les babouches et 15 morts ce qui est fou
c'est que le 10 avril dernier sur l'île
de pâques
la municipalité de la ville ce soir elle
de la ville principale avait fait la
même chose avec en utilisant également
les ananas et ça n'avait pas réveiller
de polémique donc là jean michel a
précisé
le problème avec ce genre de débat c'est
que on dit toujours à la place des gens
moi ce que j'aimerais savoir si est ce
que les martiniquais ont été choqués eux
sinon je pense que c'est un message qui
s'adresse aussi aux enfants
il faut que ça va forcément ce que c'est
qu'un m c'est peut-être que ça leur
parle plus qu'on fait un objet qui sert
à je ne sais pas mais mais cette chauve
c'est une interrogation est ce qu on est
choqué par le kangourou en australie
alors être inquiet quand brooks ici
c'est la phrase mais c'est la phrase de
kelly qui est très juste c'est à dire
quoi c'est ce qu'ils voient le mal
partout qui voix qui critiquent mois
jugé j'ai eu des nouvelles de
l'australie par actif il ya des cons
coucou de menacer de tout faire sauter
même à qui on vu quand même un rôle ans
de colonialisme
voilà est d'associer on avoue t elle
après coup mais non mais c'est que ces
cultures m a limité la polynésie
française c'est chez nous c'est français
ils ont pris des noix de coco c'est pas
blessants non plus c'est sympathique il
ya plein vote coco là bas c'est plus
rigolo que de dire à m m 52 d'avoir un
maître c'est plus rigolo de mettre des
noix de coco je voulais juste préciser
avant avant d'entendre twitter dire des
bêtises
oui la martinique c'est la france j'ai
dit en français des coquelicots en
métropole et des coquelicots voilà je
précise parce que les gens deviennent
dingues alors à mina à moi
personnellement ça m'a pas choqué mais à
partir du moment où ça tout certaines
personnes si on peut le modifier pour
quoi pas vraiment à mettre c'est un
maître pourquoi mettre des uns la
promesse des koalas pourquoi il acquis
cinq ans l'aah un kangourou c'est un
kangourou bbc un kangourou mes moyens
rudy l'ananas en mai 5 comment tu peux
ça fait vraiment être c est un grand de
la mara et les gens accessibles à tous
la raison disait m pour moi ça ahmed
c'est pour les analphabètes qui savent
pas lire et que ça ne peut être qu'une
image par le plus léché pour les
anciennes je pensais à baptiser après
voilà ma prison bien fait quand même de
le retirer parce que si ça a pu heurter
des gens voilà